foreign
[Music]
news some of the movies and actors we
didn't expect to see again are making a
comeback Gal Gadot talks about Wonder
Woman 3 there's the Star Wars series
Lando and Quentin Tarantino himself
wants to bring Bruce Willis back to the
big screen we also talk about Dungeons
and Dragons too a sequel to cocaine bear
and plenty of theatrical release
postponements here are the details
cocaine plus bear equals success cocaine
bear was a true surprise hit earlier
this year director Elizabeth Banks has
now expressed her views on a possible
sequel to The Horror comedy it's not
much of a surprise that there's a lot of
interest in a cocaine bear too after all
part 1 grossed over 89 million dollars
while it only cost 30 to 35 million
dollars to make now in an interview with
Rolling Stone magazine Elizabeth Banks
openly expressed her thoughts about a
sequel during the filming of cocaine
bear she was already thinking about
another part and how hooked she would be
by the thought of exploring this world
further she affirmed that she would like
to amaze the audience again fun was the
focus during the whole project and in
the end it was passed on to the audience
cocaine bear is Loosely based on the
story of a black bear that got a hold of
almost 15 million dollars worth of
cocaine and then started terrorizing
people in a forest safe to say the
actually absurd premise alone was enough
to draw a lot of people to the movies so
what would a way to set a sequel more
animals more drugs we are very curious
to find out
hope dies at last a possible Dungeons
and Dragons sequel could come about
after all but only under certain
conditions the new film version of the
popular Fantasy game was actually well
received by viewers and critics alike
those familiar with the original in
particular saw it as a successful
adaptation of the story at the box
office however Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves failed to impress
and is considered one of the year's big
flops a disappointment for all those who
had hoped for the start of a new and
promising fantasy film series Dungeons
and Dragons 2 is not entirely off the
table yet however despite its lack of
success Paramount Pictures CEO Brian
Robbins told Variety in an interview
that he could imagine a sequel due to
the tremendous reception for part 1
provided that the sequel could be
produced at a lower cost thus there is
still faith in the potential of the
franchise one possibility to keep the
franchise alive would be to create a
Dungeons and dragon series for the
in-house streaming service Paramount
plus of course these are only
speculations at the moment the fact is
that those responsible are convinced
that the movie is a good adaptation even
if the target audience was perhaps
smaller than expected a sequel should
thus not fail due to a lack of Interest
well Wonder Woman 3 will also find a
place in the future DCU under James Gunn
after all Gal Gadot will be part of
developing the new adventure alongside
him the future of Wonder Woman in the
new DC Universe led by James Gunn and
Peter saffron was long deemed uncertain
the superheroine made her last
appearance in Shazam 2 but was nearly
cut out of the flash fans wondered
whether there would even be a third part
in the DCU in an interview with
comicbook.com which was conducted before
the current strike Wonder Woman actress
Gal Gadot revealed that she is working
on specific plans for an additional film
this one would of course be made under
the supervision of James Gunn though Gal
Gadot will also be involved in its
development her love for the character
would continue and that's why she would
love to slip into the superheroine's
costume once again who will be in charge
of directing the movie remains unknown
Patty Jenkins who directed the first two
parts is not believed to return as her
original plans for part 3 were rejected
by James Gunn it therefore remains to be
seen But Wonder Woman 3 will look like
in what role Wonder Woman will play in
the new DC Universe we'll be sure to
keep you up to date
Star Wars fans will listen up Lando
Calrissian is getting his own series
after all after some uncertainty about
the project Disney has finally given the
go-ahead and published details about the
director as well as the lead actor the
last time we saw the Gambler was in Solo
a Star Wars story a movie that fell
short of expectations in response to the
flop of solo Disney put all plans for
additional spin-offs on hold accordingly
it also became quiet concerning a
planned Lando series now however the
project Is On The Rise Again variety
magazine reports that the series is to
be released this decision was probably
also influenced by the success of Andor
which thrilled both critics and fans
Donald Glover will again take on the
role of Lando Calrissian but not only
that he will also direct together with
his brother the Glover Brothers already
proved with their series Atlanta and
swarm that they have a talent for
comedic and dramatic themes a convincing
realization of the Lando story should
therefore be absolutely achievable
concrete information about the plot and
release date of the series are not
available yet nevertheless there is a
good reason to be happy now that the
project has any future at all until the
official premiere of Star Wars Lando
fans can look forward to the series
Ahsoka which is set to kick off in
August and is also a true fan favorite
it was to be expected the ongoing
writers and actor strike for better
working conditions is causing chaos at
the studios in response Sony announced
the rescheduling of several Productions
get ready for the new release dates the
writers and actor strike is currently
shutting down Hollywood and ensuring
that many studios Now find themselves
facing the challenge of whether they
still want to release their movies this
year the first postponements have
already been made and Zendaya film
Challengers has already been pushed back
to next year and the hotly anticipated
science fiction sequel Dune part 2 may
also fall victim to the postponement
plans now Sony announced that they will
not be releasing several Productions
this year thus giving in to the pressure
of the strikers among those affected is
the eagerly awaited Craven the hunter
with Aaron Taylor-Johnson which has been
pushed back by a full year to August
30th 2024 the sequel Ghostbusters 2
moves to March 29 2024 and the finale of
Miles Morales as Spider-Man and
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse is
being postponed for an indefinite period
of time it is currently expected to be
released in 2025. the game movie
adaptation Gran Turismo faces a minor
delay only and will now hit selected
theaters over the weekends of August
11th and August 18th expanding wide on
August 25th 2023 while The Next Karate
Kid movie is currently scheduled for
December 13 2024. however there is also
reason to Rejoice because Ben item 3
with Tom Hardy is finally getting a
fixed release date of July 12 2024 and
the Bad Boys Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence are also returning to the big
screen on June 14 2024 already nothing
is known about potential postponement
plans of the other Studios yet however
it can be assumed that further delays
will likely not be limited to Sony
Productions
a possible sensation Bruce Willis could
return in front of the cameras one last
time for the new Quentin Tarantino movie
the movie critic this rumor is based on
a personal request of the director who
already has very concrete plans for the
actor's role in mind the fate of Bruce
Willis is on the minds of countless fans
and colleagues the actor who suffers
from dementia only let it be known in
2022 that he would end his acting career
a speech disorder diagnosed in the
course of the disease affected Willis's
last working years which is why he was
mainly seen in smaller roles only
according to the Daily Express his good
friend and master director Quentin
Tarantino has now expressed his wish to
cast the actor in his final feature the
movie critic this could happen for
example as part of a cameo appearance an
alternate option would be to use a
shorter clip of Willis from his older
films in case the star couldn't make it
due to health reasons after all
Tarantino says he wants to pay tribute
to Willis by giving his fans one last
glimpse of him on the big screen
precisely where an iconic actor should
be however he would also take into
account any objections and wishes made
by what was his family the 10th and last
movie by Quentin Tarantino the movie
critic could be released in cinemas next
year with filming scheduled to start
this September it tells the story of a
man in the 1970s who writes movie
reviews for porn magazines apart from
the rumors concerning Bruce Willis
nothing is known about the cast so far
what do you think about the idea of
bringing the actor back in front of the
camera one last time should he be left
in peace or would it be a fitting and
culminating end to his career let us
know in the comments
in addition to the news there were also
some exciting previews of upcoming
movies and Series this week on our
Channel you can find the new trailers
for Loki season 2 and the horror movie
Saw Tim if you enjoyed this video feel
free to give it a thumbs up and let us
know what you think of the comments
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next week for more kenocheck news
[Music]
thank you